laetitia on à connaître un peu plus
notions de connais très bien en jouant
avec les chroniqueurs à qui veut gagner
des millions c'est très simple c'est le
même casino
oui mais milos entre saint cloud au fur
et à mesure que vous répondez il ya de
l'argent à gagner pour l'association de
l'est titien en offrant ce qui lui vaut
de maîtrise oui dans mon coin et bien
sûr que c'est vrai les mecs
chaque fois qu'il ya quelqu'un je lui
donnais de losail c'est vrai mais non
mais non elle ne savait pas c'est cool
merci me sentais beaucoup de peine à
chaque question correspond à panier pour
gagner de l'argent et bien sûr vous avez
le droit à un joker l'appel à un rami à
tout moment on peut appeler mon ami adil
rami faut l'appeler et lui poser une
question d'accord la cape
j'appellerai mon ami est dure à mi
championnat attention c'est parti
ozoir qui veut gagner des millions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est la première question à l'effort
gouverneur pour 150 euros
laëtitia a prêté sa voix pour le cinéma
qui doublées tél barbie jason statham la
schtroumpfette ou un oiseau dont l'âge
de glace
bernard généreux 150 on non non pas me
tue pas nous regarder en même temps
additionnel au ciel oui une soul
je vous sous le parvis et l'avait fait
l'année passée et là d un oiseau dans
l'âge de glace
laetitia belle marianne dix jeunes
mauvaise magic city est une mauvaise
réponse
lundi c'était la schtroumpfette
c'était en 2017 elle était aux côtés de
gérard hernandez et arié elmaleh vous
d'oublier l'âge qu'on fait ce qu'on
pouvait nous faire acheter en fait mon
dieu mais il a raté
il a raté la question ses études en fait
vous venez juste de faire gilles verdez
la mort enfin mais ça peut passer aux
actes attention ressiot mais c'était
génial publie aller c'est quoi on passe
puisque mondial y est fatigué oui on
aime beaucoup
barbie question pour valérie bénaïm way
question pour 500 euros en 2000 laetitia
fait sa première apparition à la télé
dans quelle émission le juste prix tout
le monde en parle
le millionnaire bon c'est bon choix même
mois on ne vous le savez pas mais moi je
sais pas si c'est la peña et moi je sais
moi c'est votre choix
tu sais mon choix et vous êtes très très
bon mais non la béate en bleu c'est
votre dernier mot valérie bénaïm way
regardez la réponse en images ça c'est
du bon oui si ça c'est pas que ça manque
de filles un peu là non ouais tiens à
vous ça vous embête pas j'avais pas les
défauts laetitia doit intervenir quand
vous voulez sinon tout le monde n'a pas
le thierry ardisson ses entrées comme ça
vous êtes au public oui c'est ça mais en
fait là je m'occupais du public des
émissions en haletant un petit peu botha
tendon être du coup je m'occupe et
c'était un moment où je m'occupais du
public des émissions est effectivement
walheim adaptateur il manquait
d'ailleurs il manquait de personnes dans
le public donc je me suis mise à wayne
n'était pas du tout préparé à ça en fait
physiquement parlant je sais pas si vous
voyez mais j'étais pas du tout préparés
on croyait plus que vous avez joué dans
alerte à malibu 1
mais je n'étais pas du tout finalement
je suis passé il m'a appelé je fais
seulement pourquoi ils m'appellent et
puis hop enfin voilà j'étais ça a été ma
première télé les victoriens et j'étais
très très très intimidé ben je sais pas
mais en tout cas vous avez passé très
bien déjà lente et ben j'en sais rien
mais ces derniers tout plein de
personnes qui passent sous la troisième
question olala willow steevy boulay
wolof laëtitia milot a été l'égérie
d'une grande marque pour qu'elle produit
at-elle prêter son image de la lingerie
du gel douche d assurance ou une marque
de lave linge nommé plus belles laverie
c'est déjà une biche ouais mais ne plus
jalouse pour la retourner la question
voire mauvaise
c'est en 2005 elle faisait 2 mois de
janvier du calendrier aubade
bah oui j'ai confondu avec en même temps
il a raison parce que le gel douche j'ai
été j'ai été l'égérie du petit olivier a
normalement je suis désolé il a gagné
banon mais si je devais aller vu une
marque de chips regardez ce qui s'est
passé vous savez c'est pas au vieux
singe qu'on apprend à faire
quatrième question pour 1500 euros voilà
engaly medvedi presse à l'élysée par le
mannequinat et la comédie
laetitia collaborait avec un autre
artiste dans un autre domaine lequel
elle a sorti une bd nommé tintin et
milou
elle a patiné avec philippe candeloro
est la danse à l'opéra de paris avec
benjamin millepied où elle a chanté avec
vincent nick lowe à la chanter avec
vincent miklos sûr et certain pour 1500
euros à la chanteuse mais une fois que
c'est sa réponse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va jouer là dedans avec une cinquième
question enlevé là c'est un pote arrêtés
ils ont mis un truc
j'aime bien ça aussi c'est qu'on n'était
pas des trucs à l'antenne il son bec
alors à moi pour outil on va jouer avec
vous isabelle morini bosc
on va savourer je vais vous dire c'est
ou 3000 euros pour l'association 0 oui
j'ai refait derrière un camion ya pas de
panier ce quotidien le seul panier c'est
pour regarder si vous allez sauter
attention c'est balisé en question pour
isabelle morini-bosc bezzaz isabelle oui
pourquoi tu cries ses cuisses
[Applaudissements]
elle rigole
isabelle sait où 3000 euros ou 0 c'est
de toi avec eux sur invite un ouais je
les adore mais je sais qu'elle est la
plus grande phobie de laëtitia milot au
palazzo le match j'ai dit c'est facile
on enlevait non mais vous êtes sûr je
vais mémorisées oui je vais lui répéter
rendre som rugby de laëtitia milot les
fêtes foraines les bananes les émissions
présentées par michel cymes où les
cafards
rien n'est jamais retourné chez moi tout
a commencé maintenant les fêtes foraines
ont les cafards rahan commune d'athis à
milos et les cafards mais quoi que vous
avez dans les trois de devant les quatre
bananes et aussi je pense pas les
bananes à silwan faut maintenant les
bananes
c'est un problème fête foraine pourrait
ne pas aimer les fêtes foraines j'aime
bien le nord on embrasse tous les points
d'ailleurs il faut qu'on traite donc les
cafards par élimination non mais ça
c'est un droit qui ne sais moi de le
dire
regardez réponse en images et à stevie
avec vous bah oui ah non c'est vrai oui
je voulais faire une réservation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
laëtitia milot vous allez
[Applaudissements]
l'association rando france ça nous fait
plaisir laetitia milot